the way I write and the way I've written  with Noah is that the script is really a  pretty set document and you don't change  anything you don't change any of the  word there's no improv I'm not  interested in it he's not interested in  it it's that thing when you're with  someone and you love them and they know  it and they love you and you know it but  it's a party I feel like the kind of  writing I like is the kind of writing  that one might think is improv like  Kenneth Lonergan his writing does not  sound like writing but it definitely is  writing I know you never maybe you don't  want to talk to me my heart was broken  because it's always gonna be broken but  I know yours is broken too the same  thing I felt about Mike Lee the British  director's movies I don't know any other  way to describe it but there's something  about the way he works where it's like  you use that improvisational impulse and  then you set it and then you make the  thing that is your person in this life